President Trump getting a lot of
criticism these days pick pick the
reason you want President Trump now been
getting a lot of criticism for ignoring
Puerto Rico yeah well guess what folks
here's the latest today Trump announced
he will visit Puerto Rico next Tuesday
and survey the storm damage so he's
gonna go yeah he may have to cancel
depending on what happens on Monday
Night Football
speaking of football an employee for the
Buffalo Bills quit after the entire team
took a knee during the national anthem
on Sunday yeah meanwhile an employee for
the Los Angeles Chargers quit after
watching them play
that was me acting out a guy quitting's
queueing down and I hear is goes it's
been revealed that a tweet president
Trump sent out yesterday about Iran
testing a ballistic missile was based on
old news footage yeah
even worse most of trumps complaints
about the NFL were based on the movie
Rudy that kids too young to play hey
this is nice today the nominations for
the Latin Grammys were announced yeah
yeah very nice the two contenders for
song of the year our despedido and the
song that will lose to DES Pacita thank
you that's probably what will happen
yeah in Boston experts believe they have
found Paul Revere's outhouse and they
say they are excited to examine his
fecal matter
yes these experts have been described as
single these are guys that don't get a
hot
[Music]
you